the Joe Rogan experience like Game of
Thrones they talk like us but they
didn't talk about us
yeah they had some weird lingo back well
the game of Thrones is obviously fake
but it was supposed to be a long time
ago right yeah and I'm sure they
research I mean everything about that
show was so authentic I'm sure they went
back and tried to find the way people
spoke at that time well not really it's
not really about a time it's about a
Fantasyland well it was I think it was
the War of the Roses it was based on
which was I think around the first
century wasn't it yeah but they got
[ __ ] the Dark Knight's and yeah white
knights or well yeah no they mixed a lot
of it to get King but I think there was
a point where the where the the the
British Empire was divided into whatever
it was five or six different oh yeah
that we're all fighting for the throne
apparently not they're gonna do a
pre-cool now like those guys that were
not gonna do it they were gonna cancel
it but they're gonna do it now I heard
it got canceled yeah yeah but there was
just something a couple of days ago that
said they're they're doing a preview
hundreds of years before
that's about the Targaryen that's
awesome [ __ ] yeah get back after it you
[ __ ] come on gang and give me anything
the thing about that show is they kill
everybody so they could always have new
people yeah they [ __ ] kill everybody
under the red wedding holy [ __ ] here go
HBO finally issued a statement on the
canceled its canceled thumbs down
what yeah what what do they say what's
their statement they're bringing back
Arles so they need space that's why you
want an Emmy ladies and gentlemen that's
right it what is the statement do they
have a good a good excuse what could
their good excuse be we suck and we hate
money just as they decide not to move
forward with this [ __ ] out of here well
part of the problem is that who's the
guy that wrote all the that wrote the
books that it was based on and he wrote
the first George Martin George Martin
wrote all them until they got to the
last season at last two seasons and then
he ran out of steam and that's why they
weren't as good people say that last
season wasn't as good as the rest
because it was the
showrunners that admitted I thought the
last season was excellent up until the
last episode last episode was kind of
like how do we end this
yeah let's meet the guy in the
wheelchair King yeah let's make him gay
- yeah it's just come on man yeah you
know yeah they didn't they didn't you
know and you think about the last
episode of any show is gonna get a lot
remember how much [ __ ] Seinfeld got for
the last episode cuz they didn't do
anything and Game of Thrones did the
same thing they've they punted yeah they
didn't go for anything
[Applause]